[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend man
merkt es längst an allen Ecken und Enden
die Post die nicht mehr regelmäßig kommt
die langen Schlangen vor der Sicherheit
an Flughäfen die Reinigung die ihre
Öffnungszeiten reduziert der Handwerker
der auf Wochen keine freien Termine hat
das liegt nicht nur an den aktuell hohen
Krankenständen der Mangel an
Arbeitskräften ist strukturell
insbesondere der Mangel an Fachkräften
mit durchaus bedrohlichen Folgen für die
Wirtschaft fast jedes zweite Unternehmen
klagt über Einschränkungen in der
Produktion bei Personal fehlt
Arbeitsmarktforscher gehen von 1,8
Millionen offenen Stellen aus bei der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit gemeldet sind
fast 850.000 sie stellte heute die
aktuellen Arbeitsmarktzahlen vor und
demnach ist die Erwerbstätigkeit
hierzulande auf einem Rekordniveau
Melanie Hack Bericht
es sind Triebwerke für
Langstreckenflieger die Sie hier im
thüringischen Arnstadt warten und
reparieren
15.000 Einzelteile Technik die
Fachkräfte braucht die Firma N3 sucht
Mitarbeiter weltweit im März kam Joko
Paulo aus Portugal
Germany
Deutschland hat viele Unternehmen und
viel Industrie sie suchen Ingenieure ich
fand diese Ausschreibung im Internet
dann hatte ich drei Bewerbungsgespräche
und bekam dann den Job
die Firma will erweitern sucht 200 neue
Mitarbeiter bei der Auswahl sind sie
mittlerweile flexibel und Schulen
branchenfremde Fachkräfte auch selbst zu
schwierig sei die Anerkennung von
Abschlüssen außerhalb der EU bemängelt
der Geschäftsführer
und da würden wir uns eine höhere
Flexibilisierung auch wünschen darüber
hinaus ist es sicherlich auch wichtig
dass die Rahmenbedingungen entsprechend
durch die öffentliche Hand auch
geschaffen werden also Stichwort ÖPNV
Wohnraum gerade in ländlichen Regionen
wie hier der Fachkräftemangel steigt und
beeinflusst mittlerweile fast jedes
zweite Unternehmen in der
Geschäftstätigkeit Lücken bei
Sozialarbeit Pflege Handwerk Logistik
Dienstleistung oder it der Arbeitsmarkt
im vergangenen Jahr trotz Krisen robust
erklärt Andrea Nahles heute bei der
Vorstellung der Zahlen und
Beschäftigungszuwachs vor allem durch
Menschen ohne deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit und der
Personalbedarf steige weiter wir müssen
die Fachkräfte Lücke füllen auch mit
Leuten aus dem Inland wir haben immer
noch ein hohes Potenzial bei Frauen die
in Deutschland überwiegend Teilzeit
arbeiten auch Arbeitslose die eine gute
Qualifizierung bekommen können
integriert werden das heißt zum ersten
mal gucken was haben wir einen eigenen
Potenzialen aber auch Hürden abbauen für
Zuwanderung aus Drittstaaten diese
Hürden will die ampelregierung senken
Eckpunkte für ein neues Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz sollen noch in
diesem Jahr beschlossen werden wir
brauchen eine ganz konkrete
einwanderungsstrategie in der
angabestrategie das geht nur wenn
Wirtschaft Staat und Gewerkschaften
gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass wir eine
solche anwerbestrategie haben das heißt
wir gehen gezielt auf bestimmte Länder
zu in denen wir Fachkräfte für bestimmte
Branchen auch vermuten Yogo Paulo aus
Portugal lebt sich langsam ein in
Arnstadt ob für immer offen
mein Plan ist die nächsten fünf Jahre
hier zu bleiben und mich zu
spezialisieren danach weiß ich noch
nicht
Fachkräfte auch langfristig halten denn
Deutschland geht in Rente laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit brauche es
jährlich 400.000 Zuwanderer um diese
Lücke auszugleichen
der Bundesarbeitsminister ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr hi guten
Abend Frau Slomka eine Zuwanderung von
400.000 pro Jahr das klingt irgendwie
ähnlich wahrscheinlich wie 400.000
Wohnungen die neu gebaut werden oder
Fachkräfte Sicherung ist
wohlstandssicherung wir müssen sowohl
alle inländischen Potenziale heben da
geht zum Ausbildung um Weiterbildung
Frauen Erwerbsbeteiligung aber es beißt
die Maus keinen Faden ab wir brauchen
qualifizierte Zuwanderung und zwar
deutlich mehr als in der Vergangenheit
wir brauchen alle helfenden Hände und
klugen Köpfe in Deutschland damit wir
unseren Wohlstand sichern können aber
das scheint ja nicht so richtig zu
funktionieren also es gibt offenbar
immer noch Hürden Familiennachzug ist
ein Problem Abschlüsse die nicht
anerkannt werden wie soll die nicht
erteilt werden also so viele Unternehmen
sind es nicht die jetzt aus nicht
EU-Ländern Zuwanderer haben das ist
richtig und das werden wir und müssen
wir gemeinsam ändern wenn ich sage wir
mal nicht Wirtschaft und Staat gemeinsam
deshalb werden wir modernes
Einwanderungsrecht schaffen in
Deutschland wir werden Bürokratie
abbauen würden runterbringen wir werden
ermöglichen das Berufsanerkennung von
qualifizierten auch auf deutschen Boden
stattfinden kann und wir werden ein
Punktesystem schaffen nach kanadischem
Vorbild all das ist notwendig denn mit
der Arbeitsmarkt stabil bleibt wir haben
jetzt rekordbeschäftigung über 45
Millionen Menschen sind erwerbstätig so
viel wie noch nie im wiedervereinigten
Deutschland aber wir werden auch erleben
dass viele den Arbeitsmarkt verlassen
das ist der demografische Wandel die
Babyboomer werden in Rente gehen und
deshalb ist es notwendig das besser und
unbürokratischer zu organisieren dann
haben wir aber auch nach wie vor sie
sagten ist ja schon auch ein
inländisches Problem also wir haben nach
wie vor zwei Millionen Arbeitslose warum
es ist das so schwer und das ist ja ein
altes Problem so schwer die in den
Arbeitsmarkt zu bekommen wir haben vor
allen Dingen Rückgang der
Arbeitslosigkeit erlebt über die letzten
Jahre viele Menschen sind in Arbeit
gekommen aber wir haben verfestigten
Sockel von Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit und
zwei Drittel der Langzeitarbeitslosen
Menschen haben keinen abgeschlossenen
Berufsabschluss und das werden wir jetzt
mit dem Bürgergeld ändern da steht im
Mittelpunkt Qualifizierung das Nachholen
eines Berufsabschlusses damit wir
Menschen dauerhaft eine Arbeit bringen
das hilft auch bei der
Fachkräftesicherung
und fördern aber es scheint ein Sockel
zu geben von Menschen die wirklich
eigentlich sehr schwer auch weiter zu
qualifizieren und wieder zurück in eine
Tätigkeit zu bringen sind aber das ist
der Unterschied zum alten
Hartz-IV-System da stand im Mittelpunkt
die Menschen irgendwie in Arbeit zu
bringen in der Realität sind dann viele
mal in Hilfstätigkeiten gelandet und das
Jobcenter hat sie nach ein paar Monaten
wieder gesehen jetzt gibt es die
Möglichkeit ein Berufsabschluss
nachzuholen also auch das wird ein
Beitrag leisten dazu müssen wir mehr bei
der Ausbildung tun das ist eine ganz
ganz wichtige Sache dass wir
Berufsorientierung an Schulen in
Deutschland durchsetzen gerade fürs
Handwerk ist das ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Job den wir zu tun haben also alle
Kräfte auf Fachkräfte Sicherung das ist
mein Job aber es ist auch der Job von
Wirtschaft und Staat gemeinsam sprechen
Sie ein ganz ganz großes Problem Thema
an also wir haben knapp 50.000
Schülerinnen und Schüler die ohne
manchmal Hauptschulabschluss geschafft
haben ohne Abschluss von der Schule
gehen wir haben so an die 20% der ich
glaube 20 bis 34-Jährigen keine
Berufsausbildung haben in Österreich
gibt es zum Beispiel eine Verpflichtung
eine Berufsausbildung zu machen wäre das
auch für Deutschland angedanke wir
beginnen in ähnlichen Weg wir werden
einen aus- und Weiterbildungsgesetz
beschließen mit dem wir versuchen jedem
jungen Menschen eine Chance zu geben auf
Ausbildung wir haben regionalzimmerliche
Unterschiede in einigen Bereichen
schreiben sich junge Menschen immer noch
nach einer Ausbildung die fingerwund in
anderen Bereichen werden händeringend
ausbildungskräfte gesammelt gesucht und
deshalb ist beruflich an Schulen ganz
ganz wichtig aber es ist auch wichtig
dafür zu sorgen dass wir denjenigen die
durch den Rost gefallen sind auch eine
zweite Chance geben denn sie haben
vollkommen recht wir haben auf der einen
Seite Fachkräftemangel und wir haben 1,3
Millionen Menschen zwischen 20 und 30
ohne berufliche Erstausbildung da müssen
wir genauso ran wie beim Thema Frauen
Erwerbsbeteiligung auch da stecken
Arbeitskräfte die wir schon längst in
Deutschland haben das noch mal
nachzufragen was zum Beispiel in
Österreich ist das ist jetzt nicht ihr
Plan wir werden Unternehmen unterstützen
und junge Leute unterstützen mit
jugendberufsagenturen dafür sorgen dass
die Chance bekommen auf eine
betriebliche Ausbildung wird irgendwie
geht und wenn es nicht geht auch über
eine überbetriebliche Ausbildung aber es
muss das Ziel sein dass uns weniger
durch die Ritzen fallen als in der
Vergangenheit denn das ist der Nachwuchs
für die Grundsicherung den wir
produzieren auf der anderen Seite vielen
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte da werden wir
mit Macht rangehen das ist mein Ziel es
fehlen auch welche weil viele früher in
Rente gehen als eigentlich vorgesehen
das haben sie auch unterstützt früher
Rentner aufzustocken Rente mit 63 ist
Prestige Projekte SPD ist das eigentlich
so noch durchzuhalten erstmal ist die
Zahl der Beschäftigten über 60 bis 64
massiv gestiegen das war bei 2000 im
Jahr 2000 mal bei ich glaube 10 oder 15%
sind über 60 aber wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass Menschen auch
beschäftigungsfähig sind das heißt dass
sie gesund sind in Arbeit dass sie auch
qualifiziert sind und übrigens das auch
Unternehmen Menschen über 60 einstellen
die ganze Mentalität dass man
Beschäftigte über 60 zum alten eisenpark
die können wir uns ökonomisch nicht mehr
leisten also es geht um
Beschäftigungsfähigkeit und es geht um
flexible Übergänge in den Ruhestand das
ist genau der richtige Weg ich mache es
mal in zahlen wir haben jetzt zwischen
60 und 64 61 Prozent Beschäftigungsquote
wenn wir das auf 70% steigern könnten
wenn das zusätzlich 700.000
qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte die wir
schon haben mit Erfahrung mit Ausbildung
und das ist genauso ein Potenzial das
für angehen werden sagt der
Bundesarbeitsminister danke für das
Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
haben wir vor einer Stunde geführt und
blicken jetzt in die USA denn dort tut
sich erstaunliches zum ersten Mal seit
100 Jahren hat ein Politiker ist nicht
geschafft zum Vorsitzenden des
Repräsentantenhauses gewählt zu werden
obwohl seine Partei dort die Mehrheit
hat auch wenn es vom parlamentarischen
System her nicht vergleichbar ist von
der politischen Dramatik her wäre das
ungefähr so als hätten bei uns nach der
Bundestagswahl die Unionsabgeordneten
Friedrich Merz als Fraktionschefin
Oppositionsführer durchfallen lassen
wobei das Amt des speaker of the Haus in
Washington weit machtvoller ist dem
Republikaner Kevin mit Kaffee ist es im
ersten Anlauf jedenfalls nicht gelungen
genug Stimmen aus den eigenen Reihen zu
bekommen
als Kevin McCarthy für sich selbst
stimmt spenden sie im Beifall aber es
ist ein Desaster für ihn und die
republikanische Partei sie hat zwar die
Mehrheit und doch hat am Ende des ersten
Wahlgangs der Demokrat Hakim jeffreeze
die Nase vorn
zwei 212 Stimmen für ihn sorry real die
Gegner McCarthys feiern wie sich ihre
Partei zerfleischt 19 gegen Stimmen
bekommt er und sucht dann Rat vor einem
neuen Anlauf
dabei war er doch so selbstbewusst an
diesem Morgen dass er das dritthöchste
Amt im Staat Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses bekommen würde
seine Sachen hatte er schon ins Büro
bringen lassen von dem aus bisher Nancy
die Dinge lenkte wer den Hammer hält
bestimmt nämlich über welche Themen in
der Parlamentskammer entschieden wird
über welche nicht der Kaffee droht mit
knallharter Politik und
Untersuchungsausschüssen gegen den
Präsidenten die
Ära der demokratischen ein Parteien
Herrschaft ist vorbei es gibt wieder
Kontrolle des amerikanische Volk redet
mit beim Regieren
aber ihnen ist er nicht radikal genug
die Trump Anhänger kündigten den
Aufstand an
zu legen können wir nicht den größten
Alligator beauftragen
sowohl des Landes des Kongresses und der
Fraktion sollte er abtreten es geht
nicht um Ambition Stolz oder Eigennutzes
geht nicht um eine Person
bei der Fraktionssitzung am Morgen
schrie mit Kafi seine Gegner an weil sie
posten forderten für ihre Stimmen
es könnte heute eine Schlacht werden
aber für die Fraktion und fürs Land das
ist für mich okay es wurde ein Test für
die Selbstachtung eines Politikers eine
Schlacht wie lange nicht historisch denn
zuletzt vor hundert Jahren 1923 wurde
ein Sprecher nicht im ersten Wahlgang
gewählt
1855 schaffte es eine ferngeorg banks
erst nach 133 Abstimmungen auch das
scheint nicht mehr ausgeschlossen zum
zweiten Wahlgang ein flammender Appell
von Jim Jordan McCarthy sei der richtige
den Demokraten zu zeigen wo der Hammer
hängt doch die abtrünnigen schlagen
zurück nominieren kurzerhand
eben jenen Jim jongen für Beobachter ein
Zeichen für die Unfähigkeit der
Republikaner zu regieren am Ende
scheitert McCarthy ein zweites Mal die
Schlacht geht weiter und solange bleibt
die Politik im Kongress in Washington
gelernt
schalten wir noch aktuell nach
Washington Emma wie geht's denn da jetzt
weiter
ja McCarthy so hören wir will weiter
antreten das heißt er setzt auf
Nervenkrieg und das am Ende die anderen
nachgeben werden und das könnte dann
heute weitere Wahlgänge geben auch in
den nächsten Tagen aber wir hören auch
in den letzten Minuten Stimmen von
republikanischen Abgeordneten die für
mehr Kaffee gestimmt haben aber jetzt so
ein bisschen ins Nachdenken kommen weil
sich für sie abzeichnet dass er am Ende
niemals diese Mehrheit von 218 Stimmen
bekommen würde und deswegen beginnt dann
sicherlich auch bald die Suche wer
könnte dann die Person sein das Problem
ist wer immer es ist ist dann auch
wieder abhängig von den Rechtsradikalen
in der eigenen Partei danke schon einmal
für diese aktuellen Informationen und
wie das in Washington dann in den
nächsten Stunden weiter geht darüber
halten sie nachher die Kollegen von
heute journal Update auf dem Laufenden
und jetzt geht es bei Dir weiter
heinzunächst mit der Lage in der Ukraine
oder ukrainische Militär gab heute einen
weiteren Artillerieschlag bekannt bei
dem in der Silvesternacht hunderte
russische Soldaten getötet worden sein
sollen und zwar im Gebiet herrson im
Süden des Landes erst gestern hatte Kiew
von einem Schlag gegen die russischen
Besatzer in der Ostukraine an Silvester
mit hunderten Toten berichtet das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
räumte dort den Tod von 63 Rekruten ein
erstmals ist ein reines Tankschiff mit
einer vollständigen Ladung flüssig
Erdgas am schwimmenden lng-anleger in
Wilhelmshaven angekommen laut dem
Betreiber Juniper war der Tanker mit ca
170.000 Kubikmetern verflüssigt dem
Erdgas beladen genug um rund 50.000
Haushalte ein Jahr lang mit Energie zu
versorgen das Mitte Dezember eröffnet
Terminal soll dazu beitragen die Lücke
bei der Gasversorgung Deutschlands zu
schließen die durchaus bleibende
Lieferungen aus Russland entstanden ist
nach dem Tod des emeritierten Papstes
Benedikt des 16 hat sich sein früheres
Erzbistum München und Freising mit einem
Requiem verabschiedet der jetzige
Kardinal Reinhard Marx leitete den
Gottesdienst am Abend in Münchner
Liebfrauendom zur Beisetzung Benedikt am
Donnerstag im Petersdom in Rom planen
die 27 katholischen Bistümer um 11 Uhr
ein bundesweites Trauer geläutet das ZDF
überträgt die Totenmesse ab 9:05 Uhr
[Musik]
nach den Angriffen auf polizei- und
Rettungskräfte in der Silvesternacht in
Berlin und anderen Städten wird weiter
über Konsequenzen debattiert dabei gab
die Polizei in Berlin bekannt dass alle
festgenommenen Verdächtigen nach
Abschluss der polizeilichen Maßnahmen
wieder auf freien Fuß gekommen sein nach
Angaben der Polizei zu den
Nationalitäten sind von 145
Festgenommenen 45 deutsche die anderen
stammen aus 17 weiteren Nationen
wenige Tage nach dem Amtsantritt der
neuen israelischen Regierung hat deren
Minister für nationale Sicherheit
für Juden und Muslimen bedeutsamen
Tempelberg in Jerusalem besucht wenn wir
erklärte der Tempelberg stehe allen
offen und wie ist Drohungen der
militanten Palästinenserorganisation
hamast zurück sie hatte vor einem
solchen Besuch gewarnt und mit einer
neuen Eskalation gedroht
da war er auf dem Höhepunkt seiner
Karriere seine schönsten Zeiten als
Fußballer Pelé der König wie sie ihn in
Brasilien nennen dreifache Weltmeister
und ein Spieler von ungeheurer Eleganz
und Strahlkraft das ganze Land trauert
um diese Ikone heute war die Beerdigung
Ariston Sally berichtet wie Brasilien
aber tausende begleiteten den
Feuerwehrwagen der den Sarg des
unsterblichen auf seinem letzten Weg
durch die Hafenstadt Santos fuhr
Pellet war für das Brasilien zwischen
1958 und 1970 das Wunder an dass es
glauben konnte er wurde auf dem
Fußballplatz zum Symbol für Gleichheit
und Gerechtigkeit weil weder seine
Hautfarbe noch sein sozialer stand eine
Rolle spielten Pele Verband die Armen in
den Favelas mit den Reichen in den
abgeriegelten Wohnblöcken bis heute
Brasiliens Präsident Lula da Silva der
sich der sozialen Gräben des Landes
verstärkt annehmen will stellt die
verbindende Kraft des ausnahmefußballers
heraus
die Welt verdankt Pelé einiges
insbesondere die Würde eines Mannes der
Arm und schwarz geboren wurde in einem
Land in dem noch viele Vorurteile
herrschen Pelé ließ sich davon nicht
beeinflussen
edzone
Brasiliens bester Botschafter in der
Welt ein Magier am Ball wo er auftrat
heißt es vergaßen die Menschen für einen
Moment ihren Hunger
woher kommt unser schwarzer König der
uns auf der ganzen Welt repräsentiert
hat ich bin so emotional weil ich von
ganzem Herzen Santos Fan bin
[Musik]
ich bin 1962 nach Santos gezogen und
habe hier immer Pele gesehen war bei
jedem seiner Spiele und habe keines
verpasst
ihr
er hat viel für die Kinder getan für die
Zukunft Brasiliens deshalb bin ich heute
hier
er ist unser König des Fußballs er hat
uns repräsentiert und war einfach
unglaublich
[Musik]
die letzte Fahrt des Königs endet hier
am vertikalen Friedhof der ökumenischen
Gedenkstätte nekropol der sogar im
Guinnessbuch der Rekorde steht als
höchster seiner Art Pelé hat hier schon
vor 19 Jahren im neunten Stock eine
Grabstätte erworben die Zahlen 9 eine
Hommage an seinen Vater der früher als
Spieler diese Rückennummer trug Bälle
schaut jetzt auf sein Stadion von oben
kein anderer Platz wäre angemessener für
den Schöpfer des schönen Spiels des
jorgo Bonito
und jetzt noch mal Heinz Wolf erstmal
mit Wirtschaft es gibt einen neuen
Zwischenstand zur Inflation demnach war
sie im abgelaufenen Jahr insgesamt auf
einem recauto im Dezember ging es aber
nicht mehr ganz so stark nach oben und
lag wieder unter der 10% Marke Stefanie
berrett wie werden die weiteren
Aussichten eingeschätzt also so viel
steht fest der Scheitelpunkt scheint
erreicht jetzt sollte die Inflation wenn
alles gut geht immerhin einstellig
bleiben die staatliche Übernahme des
Dezember Abschlags für Gas und die dank
Mehl im Winter moderat gestiegenden Öl
und Benzinpreise dämpften den
preisauftriebe im Dezember auf 8,6 %.
Preis Treiber Nummer 1 bleibt dabei die
Energie sie verteuerte sich zum
Jahresende um 24,4 % gegenüber dem
November jedoch ein deutlich geringerer
Anstieg erschossen die Energiepreise
noch umfasst 40% gegenüber dem Vorjahr
hoch keine Trendwende dagegen bei
Nahrungsmitteln hier hat sich die
Teuerung nur einen Hauch verlangsamt und
bleibt mit 20,7 % auf sehr hohen Niveau
November waren Nahrungsmittelpreise noch
um gut 21 Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr
gestiegen Nahrungsmittel dürften ohnehin
weiterhin tendenziell teuer bleiben auch
weil Futtermittel und saatgutpreise
kräftig gestiegen sind dennoch sind
Ökonomen optimistisch die Schätzungen
für 2023 bewegen sich zwischen 5,4 und
7,4 Prozent vor allem Strom und
gaspreisbremsen sollten die Inflation
etwas abschwächen die haben Aktienmarkt
kamen die Entspannung einer Preisfront
gut an der DAX schließt heute mit einem
Prozent von fast einem Prozent plus
Stefanie berrett vielen dank
zwei Meldungen vom Wintersport bei der
Tour de Ski in Oberstdorf hat Katharina
Hennig einen protestplatz verpasst über
die zehn Kilometer im klassischen Stil
wurde die langlaufolympiasiegerin 6 mit
rund 41 Sekunden Rückstand auf die
Siegerin Frida Karlsson aus Schweden die
die Führung in der Gesamtwertung
übernahm
der dritte Wettbewerb der diesjährigen
Vierschanzentournee morgen in Innsbruck
findet ohne Deutschlands top-springer
Karl Geiger statt er scheiterte heute an
der Qualifikation aus den Kampf um das
tourneepodest ist Karl Geiger nun
definitiv raus als 51 der Qualifikation
hat es Deutschlands derzeit
erfolgreichster Springer nicht in den
morgigen Wettbewerb geschafft nur 108
Meter für Geiger der 29-Jährige
fassungslos
dass der Sprung Zauber nix war aber ja
das ist für die Qualität nicht reicht
das ist einfach echt mies
Philipp Reimund als 11 der beste von
sechs qualifizierten deutschen den
weitesten Sprung landete der Gesamtweite
David Kubatzki aus Polen
und jetzt noch ein kino-Tipp für allein
schon die Landschaftsaufnahmen machen
diesen Film zu einem Erlebnis der
Schauplatz Irland eine fiktive Insel
namens in die sharing auf der neben
diversen Dorfbewohnern keltische Geister
sogenannte benchys unterwegs sind und
unheilvolles ankündigen vor allem aber
ist the Banshees of Initialen ein Film
über Freundschaft im Mittelpunkt zwei
Männer gespielt von Colin Farrell und
random ließen bei den Filmfestspielen in
Venedig wurde der Film schon
ausgezeichnet und für die Golden Globes
und den Oscar gilt er als Top Favorit
gut oder moritz hat den sich angesehen
eine Landschaft zu schroff wie schön
Irland vor 100 Jahren
[Musik]
die winzige Insel in die Sharon ist ein
idyllischer Ort hier passiert nichts ein
Leben in Gleichmut und voller Rituale
jeden Tag Punkt 14 Uhr holt der
pharmaportrick seinen besten Freund
collem ab auf ein Bier im Pub
dieser Teil der Welt der Westen Irlands
ist sehr besonders seine Schönheit ohne
Gleichen und die Herzlichkeit der
Menschen außergewöhnlich
doch urplötzlich kündigt können dem
jüngeren die Freundschaft und der
versteht die Welt nicht mehr
also habe ich dir was getan dann sag mir
was es war oder habe ich was falsches
gesagt vielleicht habe ich ihm so was
gesagt und es vergessen aber ich glaube
nicht dass ich ihm so was gesagt und es
vergessen habe aber wenn doch dann sag
mir was es war und ich entschuldige mich
dafür gerade
aber du hast nichts falsches gesagt
und du hast mir auch nichts getan ich
mag dich einfach nicht mehr
aus und vorbei für die ungleichen
Freunde das kann der nette etwas
einfältige Portrait nicht begreifen doch
Colin will nur noch Zeit für seine
Leidenschaft haben die Musik um jeden
Preis
ich habe folgendes beschlossen ich habe
eine große Schere daheim ich werde jedes
mal wenn du mich ab jetzt belästigst zu
dieser schwere greifen und dann schneide
ich mir einen Finger damit ab für
random ließen spielt einen Mann der etwa
50 60 Jahre alt ist ein Künstler der das
Gefühl hat Zeit zu vergeuden und über
den Tod nachdenkt und wie er im Film
sagt vielleicht bleiben wir noch zwölf
Jahre Zeitverschwendung kann ich mir
nicht mehr leisten
Colin macht die blutige Drohung wahr und
das verstört portrix sehr dessen
drastische Zurückweisung bricht ihm das
Herz die Folge Eskalation der Gewalt
Spiegelbild des blutigen Bürgerkriegs
der in der Ferne auf der Hauptinsel tobt
1923 kämpfen und sterben die ihren um
ihre Unabhängigkeit
es geht auch um die Vorstellung dass
Menschen angeblich grundlos
gegeneinander kämpfen aber wer angreift
hat immer einen Grund es geht niemals um
nichts hinter jedem Angriff steht eine
Provokation und auch davon handelt der
Film
[Musik]
stellt Fragen ist Kunst wichtiger als
Freundschaft und was zählt wirklich im
Leben Colin Farrell und Brandon ließen
laufen in ihrer irischen Heimat zur
Höchstform auf
eine tragekomödie rätselhaft und leicht
zugleich und Kandidat für noch mehr
Filmpreise
[Musik]
das war es heute journal mit der 37 Grad
Reportage die das gleich weiter heute
über eine junge Frau die mit ihrer
Adoptivmutter die leibliche Mutter in
Nepal besucht um 0.30 meldet sich dann
Gundula Gause mit unserem heute schon
mal Update und ihr morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein neues Tief
zieht auf und das hat ein umfangreiches
Regengebiet dabei das sieht über nachts
über die Mitte weiter Richtung Osten und
tagsüber kommt es dann auch im Osten an
ganzen Süden größtenteils trocken und
dieses Tief ist auch ein Sturmtief und
so gibt es sehr viel Wind zunächst
einmal Richtung Nordsee aus
südwestlichen Richtung teils mit
Sturmböen und sogar orkanartigen Böden
und auch in den höheren Lagen liegt der
Wind allmählich zu im Süden merken sie
kaum etwas davon hier bildet sich sogar
Nebel bei Temperaturen bis -2 Grad an
den Alpen und 8 Grad plus ganz im Westen
Deutschlands am Vormittag zieht dann das
Regengebiet weiter ostwärts ja dahinter
gibt es einige schauen und ganz im Süden
starten wir sogar mit Sonnenschein in
den Tag zum Nachmittag liegt der Wind in
den höheren Lagen und auch Richtung
Nordsee zu da auch noch mal orkanartige
Bönen dabei ansonsten ist das
Regengebiet vor allem im Osten
angekommen und im Süden trocken ja und
sogar Gewitter damit müssen sie auch
Rechnung rechnen Richtung Norden
Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte sieben
bis zwölf Grad ganz im Westen sogar 13
Grad ja mild geht in den nächsten Tagen
weiter Donnerstag zieht ein neues
Regengebiet auf ja am besten dagegen
Sonnenschein 7 bis 13 Grad und auch am
Freitag neue Regen am trockensten ist
noch der Samstag bei 5 bis 13 Grad und
damit ein schöner Abend